how does check justify his argument
that's the history it's up its history
it's absolutely right what I say is it's
actually exactly right look at the
history well you're a journalist Jake
how about showing us the history
documents written accounts legal
precedent I'm a comedian I'm an
entertainer and I do it why can't you
there's often times in the press and
certainly online you only see half the
Constitution in fact I've had this
tweeted to me several times this week
they say so clear it says right there
the right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed that is wow
man I don't think about that that is
that is really clear oh wait a minute
how about do the other part of the
amendment the first half of the
amendment
oh let's read the whole amendment for a
second a well-regulated militia being
necessary to the security of a free
State the right of the people to keep
and bear arms shall not be infringed ok
straw man alert listen I understand that
liberals try and paint conservatives as
stupid and conservatives try and paint
liberals as stupid I also understand
there are low information voters on both
sides okay in this situation [ __ ] is
trying to point to the Second Amendment
activists as the least educated among
the gun control debate people who
wouldn't have ever even picked up a
constitution or read the Second
Amendment let me ask you this would it
stand to reason that in this debate the
people more likely to understand the
Second Amendment would be people who've
gone through the process of purchasing a
firearm maybe becoming licensed and
concealed carry and are by law required
as they go through this course to
understand their Second Amendment rights
as it relates to their firearm ownership
and their state wouldn't it stand to
reason your honor that they might be
more likely or required to have read the
Second Amendment as opposed to Chang's
audience who has noticed there's no
necessity to read the Constitution at
all to simply hold the opinion that we
should ban guns go check out the pro-gun
sites whether it's the NRA go to a
concealed carry course when I've gone to
firearm safety courses they've given us
pocket constitutions again
look at the groups and make your own
inferences now let's get to the facts of
which he provides very little but I
promise you I'll do my due diligence
the founding fathers debated these to no
end they debated literally every comma
of the second amendment at the very last
edit they did was to take out a comma
this is true absolutely and this very
point soundly makes [ __ ] strongest
argument against him more on that later
on they had the first part the right to
keep and bear arms in the first half the
sentence in the first copy of the of
this amendment and then they switched it
after debating it so if they just wanted
to write the second half of their
amendment the right to keep and bear
arms for the people they could have just
written that it's not like they didn't
think about it they thought about it
they debated it and they decided no no
no it's very important in order for us
to have militias we need to have arms
this is for the point of a militia see
that net it's a very important qualifier
that was the whole point of them and I
see this is where shanks argument starts
to fall apart like he said the founding
fathers were incredibly careful in their
wording with the Constitution and they
did they chose to leave all of this in
so every word the fact that both clauses
are in there matters they consciously
the founding fathers chose to include
both militia comma the right of the
people shall not be in French see it
says militia as Chang said very careful
comma separation the right of the people
shall not be infringed why were they so
hell-bent on not just the militia not
just soldiers with guns but the people
having the right to bear arms Schenk
explains this with his very next
sentence in the North they had malicious
and they were there to protect a
community and sometimes they rose up
against the federal government and
George Washington had to go fight those
militias on behalf of the United States
of America hah okay so this is very
important if George Washington had to
fight malicious meaning people with guns
not necessarily soldiers with guns what
would have been the easiest way for
George Washington to ensure that these
battles didn't happen again maybe
elsewhere in the country it's an easy
answer ban guns conference Kate them
from the people
but George Washington didn't why for the
very same reason that as Chang said they
expressly allowed the people to bear
arms in the first place because the
people with weapons became a militia and
had just finished fighting off a
tyrannical government for two years the
biggest Empire the world had ever seen
up until that point and to avoid said
tyranny in the future even with
Washington knowing full well that he
could become a tyrant himself they put
the Second Amendment in for the people
as a fail-safe in the South they were
largely slave patrols they wanted to be
have everybody be able to carry arms so
that if there was a slave insurrection
they would be armed and be able to shoot
the slaves look into the history of it
that's exactly right okay this is the
big difference between someone like
chenkin myself I'm an entertainer a
comedian I don't claim to be a
journalist but when we make factual
statements at La Toya's Crider like the
Bernie video or the Detroit video each
head over 30 to 40 sources Young Turks
claims to be a news network and of
course shanks not funny
but they don't provide sources how does
Hank justify his argument that's the
history it's out it's up it's the
history it's absolutely right what I say
is it fact is exactly right look at the
history well you're a journalist Jake
how about showing us the history
documents written accounts legal
precedent I'm the comedian I'm an
entertainer and I do it why can't you
in order to protect those communities
the militias had to be armed that's why
the sentence is structured very clearly
that way if you're a strict
constructionist you can't ignore an
enormous ly important part of the
sentence you're being widely
disingenuous if you do the fact that the
Supreme Court read the first half the
scent is out of its interpretation is
insane that's just basically saying I
don't really care what the Constitution
says I'm just gonna ignore parts of it I
don't like that's what the right-wingers
who are the judicial activists on the
court did in the case of the Second
Amendment okay again no sources no facts
chanc just describes motive and lack of
intelligence to his opponent here now
considering that gun control is the
single biggest losing issue for
Democrats and one in which even far left
Democrats are willing to give as seen
with someone like Bernie Sanders in
Vermont what's more plausible that as
chanc argue
here the Supreme Court ruling to which
he's referring to will bring up on
screen as I know he didn't we're just
stupid right-wingers or that they too
had access to the information I just
provided and chanc withheld from you
again make your own entrance okay
looking at the case specifically
something [ __ ] won't tell you is that
even though the ruling was in favor of
the current interpretation of the Second
Amendment the dissenting arguments are
just as important dissenting justice
Stevens argued that the Second Amendment
only protects the rights of individuals
to bear arms as part of a well-regulated
state militia not for other purposes
even if they are lawful now why doesn't
shank tell you this maybe because even
among shanks leftist pro-gun control
audience this argument the one that
needs to be made legally would be wildly
unpopular the only way to have ruled
against the supreme court ruling
allowing for private citizens to have
guns would not be incremental gun
control would not be some kind of a
tiered assault weapons ban but a ban on
guns again we're talking legal here
Justice Breyer agreed with Stevens but
added that even if possession were to be
allowed for other reasons any law
regulating elusive firearms would have
to be unreasonable or inappropriate to
violate the Second Amendment the
dissenting judges acknowledged that to
legally rule in the other direction
would require no rights for private
citizens to own guns for hunting for
protection for target shooting nothing
they argue that maybe the government
could subjectively grant the privilege
to own firearms to some but the right to
bear arms would be all but non-existent
period and that's why people like Schenk
and leftists have to lie to their
constituency about gun control because
legally we're talking legally now when
it comes down to it the only leg they
have to stand on would be wildly
unpopular even within their own party
the other interesting part here is what
do they mean by the people it says the
right of the people to keep and bear
arms shall not be infringed now the
people can mean two different things
it could mean every person now if it
means every person then you think okay
good that I've got the right to bear
arms that's that means me or it could
mean the people of the United States so
for example they were referring to the
security of a free State and the state
is trying to protect itself against the
federal government in the context of the
founding fathers so it could mean the
people of that state
okay I'll address it but this last part
is erroneous let's move on the amendment
had said in modern times is strong
national military being necessary to the
security of a free State the right of
the people to keep and bear nuclear arms
shall not be infringed no one would
interpret that as meaning that every
single person gets to have nuclear arms
they would interpret that to mean well
since we need a strong military and
that's essential for a free State you
cannot ban nuclear arms from the people
of the United States okay there it is
here's the thing it doesn't it doesn't
say that now can we address that in the
future video sure but this video is
getting long so how about we stick to
what actually exists instead of getting
into silly hypotheticals that act only
as a vehicle for chanc to do is really
bad stupid conservative voice if you
think about arms
what is arms being in fact then it meant
muskets are there reasonable regulations
on what arms means of course does
anybody think we should have a nuclear
arms no does anybody think we should all
have a right to RPGs I hope not does
anybody look you know what essa is arms
landmines you think we all have a right
to have landmines and plant them even in
our own yard no what if fluffy your
next-door neighbor's dog comes by or
your next-door neighbor's kid comes by
as he's walking this way you know the
right time
I have landmines okay shake is either
lying or a very uninformed person here
firstly why would they need to specify
that the military had the right to
weapons as any military not had the
right to weapons oh my gosh what hall
second or no thirds going out there with
sporks we've been doing it wrong since
the beginning of ever we've addressed
this argument before in depth click this
video muskets were not the only weapons
around at that time there were
high-capacity rapid-fire assault weapons
like the deer and Dhoni air rifle the
Puckle gun the Belton flintlocks the
pepperbox revolver and yes the founding
fathers were completely aware of it they
had the chance to ban those or expressly
outline an exclusion in the Second
Amendment but they didn't it's for that
same reason that James Madison wrote a
letter of marque and reprisal to a
private ship asking if they had the
right to own cannons to protect
themselves from piracy again real
factual observe
history here will provide the links
because they don't what was Madison's
response well let's use the Chang
technique in some modern languages of
course you have the right to cannons to
protect yourself from pirates [ __ ]
that's why I wrote the second amendment
so let's follow Chang's logic here it's
a million dollars hundreds of years ago
adjusted for inflation would let's say
be over a billion dollars today I'm not
good at math let's just assume a cannon
expressly protected under the Second
Amendment hundreds of years ago when
adjusted for inflation would at least be
a high-capacity rifle if not a drone
with high-capacity magazines hanging
from its webcams not talking feelings or
opinions here pure history and law and
we have any regulation of any of our
rights well of course we've got a Reagan
reasonable regulation of any of our
rights freedom of speech is perhaps the
most important right we have as
Americans but I can't go into a crowd of
theater and yell fire because that poses
a danger to people you just think [ __ ]
would be better equipped the yelling
fire in a crowded theater to try and
regulate speech argument that's the kind
of argument you'd skim past in a high
school debate club so you could get to
the arguments that were more compelling
so you can't yell fire in a crowded
theater so speeches like freedom of
speech is regulated right you can't yell
fire in a crowded theater that wasn't a
stupid liberal voice just chinks no no
not right ok the problem with yelling
fire shank is not the speech it's a call
to action so let me use an extreme
example to make a point and then even a
less extreme example than yours to make
a point let's say a racist walks into a
black lives matter bar now it's never
actually happened but let's assume for
the sake of argument and he yells in
front of all people hey I am actually a
racist I'm a white supremacist I hate
all black people and I believe that you
are not equal to white people is that
protected yeah as horrible as it sounds
it is protected now let's change that
situation a less extreme example than
yelling fire in a crowded theater but
that same white supremacist oh brother
where art thou a KKK member walks into
the black lives matter club and he says
hey I don't know if you saw but that
black guy just robbed a liquor store you
should go beat him up get him and it's
not true that's not legal it's not the
speech it's the
all to action that's why you can be an
accessory to murder without stabbing
somebody shank seems like a bright
enough guy I don't know why he'd make
this argument I don't know why he would
act like he doesn't even have a basic
understanding of freedom of speech here
being wildly disingenuous oh I guess
that makes sense let's focus on that for
one more second - yes it's
well-regulated but if a militia was
there to protect their community for
whatever purpose back in the day
depending on where you lived in north of
the South and they needed the arms to
protect the community what would be the
modern-day equivalent of that now today
we don't have muskets anymore I'm not
sure Washington and Jefferson meant a
arse
you know 70s or ak-47s of things that
fire thirteen bullets in a second is
what they would have considered
reasonable arms he just said AR 17 in
case there were any doubt left as to how
little chanc knows about firearms he
literally just said AR 70 or maybe he's
a genius maybe he's talking about the AR
17 shotgun that was made in 1964 and
they only produced I think about 1200
worth and he just knows a ton he's like
the hipster of guns or maybe he's just
really King stupid and knows as much
about firearms as he does the Second
Amendment again make your own inferences
again watch my previous video if you
have time we went into this in a bit
more depth perfect counter-argument here
would be the Belton flintlock a
high-capacity rightful about which the
founding fathers not only knew but they
were fanboys as seen between the
correspondents of Belton and Congress
Belton described the gun as capable of
firing up to sixteen or twenty balls in
1610 or five seconds of time matter of
fact Congress actually commissioned
Belton to build or modify 100 muskets
for the military in May 3rd 1777 the
only reason the order was dismissed in
May 15th was because when Congress
received Belton's bid they considered it
to be an extraordinary allowance
basically the gun was really cool but it
was too expensive did the founding
fathers outlaw it no did they expressly
outlined that the people couldn't have a
right to it nope could they have sure
but they never did they never did and
unlike chanc who just says look it up
read the history it's exactly right I
will provide all of these sources at the
original post of this video what louder
Crider calm for you to view at your
reading pleasure matter of fact every
single point of his conjecture can be
refuted with historical evidence
documents and legal precedent at the
link below but what's the crux of his
argument how does she close it out Oh
what protects our community today police
forces so if I just think out the
ancient language and putting modern
language it reads like this a
well-regulated police force being
necessary to the security of a free
State the right of the people to keep
and bear Arms shall not be infringed
when you read it like that does that
sound like every single person gets to
have a gun no it sounds like yeah you
get to have a gun if you're part of the
police force that is protecting the
security of a free State and you're
well-regulated it's not that complicated
ah and how's that working out for you
this awkward moment where you've argued
for years that a systemically corrupt
racist American judicial institution now
becomes the one to whom you demand we
willingly give over our rights to
autonomy self protection and now for
some reason our unwavering trust and
guess what police forces are nothing new
they existed back then too
that's why the Second Amendment wasn't
written for the police force or the
militia it was the reason that comma the
right of the people was expressly
written to keep everything else in check
the founding fathers asserted that the
overwhelming amount of historical
documentation proves that and the
Supreme Court ruled that and no amount
of unsubstantiated unsourced YouTube
videos will change that hey every young
turk audience be sure to hit the dislike
button below but if for some reason you
like a video with historical
documentation and references click one
of these next to me they're also more
entertaining because not only links I
provide jokes and you might just be
offended enough to be entertained I
don't know I'll do my best